all right welcome back to CBS this
morning I'm Anthony Mason with Tony to
cope poll Gayle King is off so CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Michelle Miller
is with us hospitals across the country
are struggling to keep up as the number
of coronavirus cases surges the nation's
largest nurses union says many hospitals
are not truly ready for an influx of
people who need to be tested and treated
Adriana Diaz is at Chicago's
Northwestern Memorial Hospital Adriana
why are nurses
sounding the alarm well good morning
Anthony doctors here could protect
preparing for a potential outbreak but
National Nurses United says that nurses
that other hospitals across the country
are not getting all the tools they need
to properly treat their patients and
protect themselves we have found that
hospitals are falling short when it
comes to having enough of the protective
equipment
sandy Redding is vice president of
National Nurses United the nation's
largest nurses union she says workers
are not ready to handle coronavirus
cases we need to have face shields
gloves and special gowns instead of
locking them up and having to request
for them we want to be able to react
quickly and swiftly leaders at northwell
helps lij Forest Hills Hospital in New
York say they are ready dr. Theresa
Amato is the director of emergency
medicine what we're doing right now is
we're trying to screen for anybody that
would be at a high risk so just having a
cough and a fever sore throat doesn't
necessarily mean that you have the
corona virus we would really want to
know have you been traveling have you
been in contact with someone who has
tested positive for the corona virus to
cut down on the risk of overcrowding
some hospitals are asking patients not
to rush the emergency room first thing
you should do is to call your own
physician and speak to them over the
phone and really get advice from them of
what would be the next best step the
number one thing we do is kind of assess
their medical stability via this virtual
visit at Rush University Medical Center
in Chicago doctors are now using virtual
visits to prevent infected patients from
entering the ER dr. Mita Shah showed us
how it works
why has the hospital decided to do this
I think it's really important that the
patients get a good education be able to
talk to a medical professional well it
seems I'm being able to stay at home
when a patient's brought to the ER
they're typically dropped off here at
the main emergency room exit but any
patient that suspected of having
coronavirus is taken to this specialized
ambulance Bay where they bypassed the
emergency room and they're taken
straight up to isolation Rush University
Medical Center just cared for a person
with a confirmed case of corona virus
chief medical officer dr. Paul Casey
examined him how do you treat this
patient and still protect doctors like
yourself nurses staff so a couple of the
ways that we've done that is we have
iPads specially set up in the room but
if there's quick interactions that need
to happen they can actually do those
from outside the room the CDC's latest
guidelines for hospitals preparing for
coronavirus include telephone advice
lines and those virtual visits we showed
you now if you feel you've been exposed
to the virus doctors suggest calling the
hospital ahead before showing up to
reduce potentially exposing others
Adrianna thank you that makes perfect
sense yeah in the heads up let them put
the masks on and be ready for you yeah
and those teleconferences are a good
idea too